Okay.
So for 150 years,
organic chemists have
10 chemistry courses,
have tended to acquire
a daunting reputation.
Uh,
so you need help.
I know you're very able,
but trust me, you need help.
So where do you do to help the power
points are available on the web?
How many of you have already
seen the PowerPoint for today?
Just so I have some idea. So about
a quarter of your maybe. Okay.
But anyhow,
so your lecture notes are important but
you don't have to worry about getting
everything down cause you can download
it from the web and I do it on a Mac,
but I try my best to make it compatible
with pcs and even with the free PC
viewer for PowerPoint. So you should be
able to see it, but I don't see it on,
on a PC,
so if anything doesn't come through,
let me know so that I
can fix it. Uh, okay.
Then in class discussion is very
important and if you're really,
really shy and can't participate
in, uh, in discussion in class,
then email me a question. Okay.
There's the course website,
which is our substitute for a text that
also includes the PowerPoint and there's
the link for it. And when you go
there you'll see it, uh, develop its,
it's the current website is
mostly last year's course,
so it'll change a little
bit as we go along.
But fundamentally it's the same if you
want to look ahead and you'll see pretty
much what's coming up.
Uh,
there'll be assigned problems
and questions and also
their previous exams and
answer keys. All these things are on the
course website, so you'll get help there.
Uh, but one thing that's really
special is the course Wiki.
This is the third year.
We've done it in the second
year in a really systematic way.
So you get assigned to do,
to cover a couple of
frames of the PowerPoint.
So those are the ones you really
need to take careful notes on. Okay.
And write them up and if
and help other people too.
That's the nature of a Wiki is, you know,
how many of you participated in a Wiki?
Well, by next week it
will be all of you. Okay.
But in order to get credit for it,
you have to get it by the
night after the lecture. Right?
So for lecture today,
you have to get it by late tomorrow night,
36 hours after the lecture.
This is so other students can can use it.
Okay. In the, in the spring
they'll probably be a textbook.
I haven't really decided yet.
These things cost an arm and a leg.
Maybe we can find one
that's used that, uh, uh,
older edition that doesn't make any
difference except to the publishers.
Okay. Also, there's personal
help like from me and there's,
and you can find my phone
number, email and so on, on the,
on the website also the two
graduate student TA's who
are assigned to the course
who are Philip Collins Collins Itch,
Colin's itch fellow back there.
And Nathan,
uh, fly, not slash lie. Okay.
So these are graduate students in
chemistry and they run these, uh,
the discussion sections.
Uh,
typically you have a 50
minute discussion section,
but the way we run it in this course is
that, uh, on two different nights a week,
there are two hour sessions. You can
come to any part of it. You want to,
you can go to both of them.
You can go to four hours a week if you
want to or you can go to none at all if
you want to write.
So it really,
for the bookkeeping
purposes of the department,
you have to sign up for a section,
sign up for any section you want to write
and then come to what's useful for you.
Uh,
but also the reason you pay the big
bucks to come here is not to hear me.
It's the interact with the other students.
That's a really big help.
So form study groups,
right?
And in fact you can get advice from
previous people who've taken the course
that's on the web also.
There's some of them,
there's a list of them on the web who
would be happy to talk to you if you,
if you need it.
Uh,
and we're blessed with three
alumni seniors who took
this course as freshmen who
act as what are called peer tutors.
And they'll run a session Sunday evening
from eight to 10:00 PM is the current
plan.
We'll announce the rooms for these things
on the website and probably by email
to you as well. So let me
introduce Tina. Whoa. Okay.
And Drew Klein and Justin. Ken. So
there'll be a big help to you too.
So there's plenty of plenty of
personal help. So use it. Okay.
Uh, these are the dates. We're
going to have exams there,
10 lectures and none of the exam. Nine
lectures, exam nine lectures exam.
Actually if you check,
you'll find that uh, and the,
and also you get 50 points
for participation in the
Wiki and the total is 650
points. That's what your
grandma exam is based on. The,
actually this doesn't cover it,
that's nine lectures that are covered
on the exam, but the previous Wednesday,
part of the lecture is going to be a guest
lecturer that's going to be here just
that day.
So we're putting the exam off,
but it'll only cover the
previous material. Not that
that's a big deal. Okay.
And the semester grade is biased.
That is, it's based on this,
your total score here out of 650 points.
But if you're near a cutoff and you were
very good about turning in your problem
sets and so on, then we boost you
up. Yet we don't grade problem sets,
but if it's worthwhile to do them
right and they might make a difference.
Okay. Uh, okay. So where
are we going with this?
What are the goals of our freshmen
organic chemistry? In fact,
if you click that in your PowerPoint,
you'll get taken to that site,
but it's right on the website.
You'll see it. Anyhow. Uh,
first of is to learn the crucial facts
and vocabulary of organic chemistry after
all.
That's what we think we're here for.
And to develop a theoretical
intuition about how bonding works.
This is the goal for the primary goal of
the first half of the fall semester is
to learn how bonding works really.
Right.
And that relates that to molecular
structure and also how bonding changes.
And that of course is reactivity.
But under the line,
there are a lot of other things that we
do in freshman organic chemistry that
are arguably just important,
just as important,
like make the scientific transition
from school to university in school.
They try to teach you what
people know in the university.
You try to develop new knowledge.
So you need a different mindset for that.
And we hope this course helps you develop
that. So learn from organic chemistry,
which is really in my view, a model
science, how to be a creative scientist.
So here's, here's a creative scientist
by anybody's measure Louie poster.
And in the 1880s he said this in French,
but in English it says,
knowing to be astonished by something is
the minds first step toward discovery.
Another way of putting that is that the
characteristic comment on making a real
discovery is not Eureka.
It's, Huh, that's funny,
right?
So that's what you really have to learn.
You learn enough about how chemistry
works and formed this picture in your mind
that when something happens
that doesn't fit, you know,
to be astonished so that
you can discover something.
That's exactly what pastor did.
And we'll talk about that in the course
and even perhaps more important to
develop good taste so that you can
distinguish sense from nonsense.
There's certainly more nonsense floating
around and sense and being able to tell
the difference is important.
The way you do it is to develop good taste
by looking a lot of good examples and
then you're aware of how
crummy the bad examples are.
So we're going to try to emphasize
good examples and have fun.
Okay,
so and it as we go along here,
if you have questions break in, you'll,
you'll do this much more as we go along.
I know.
So the class really is
mostly about theory,
although we described the basis for the
theory and spend a lot of time trying to
make it real.
But we require chemistry one 26 hours.
The lab,
this is the only chemistry course that
requires you to take a lab simultaneously.
So I hope you're all enrolling in that
because there'll be a certain day that
you want to be able to take it.
It's just one afternoon, a week,
three hours or whatever it is.
But you want to get your first choice.
So line up soon you'll be accommodated.
But it's just more convenient if you
get get it arranged earlier. But why?
Because lab answers the
really big question.
And the big question was brought home to
me by my son John McBride in his third
year.
This was the beginning of the third year,
and his mother and I didn't know
what was coming for the next year,
maybe 15, maybe 20 times a day. He said,
how do you know?
Right?
So here's John this last summer.
He's now 38 and he has his own three
year olds the to say that to him and he
doesn't say, how do you know anymore?
He now says, how do you know?
Okay,
but that is the main question.
How do you know what these things
that they told you in school?
While there are four ways we
could talk about of knowing,
and two of them are shown on this,
uh,
this manuscript from the Carolingian Book
Bader. If we zoom in on the top frame,
here's Moses on Mount Sinai.
So the first way of knowing is
divine authority right here.
He's going to be the, he's the
graduate student here getting the word,
here's a teaching assistant over
on the left, perhaps parent, right?
And then he comes down from
Sinai, right? To see the class,
the children of Israel. Right? So
here's another kind of authority,
right? Which is human authority
interpreting the scriptures.
And here you can see the class. I mean,
the guys go on like, Huh? Like that.
Right? Okay. And the teaching assistant
is often, the side is still right,
but this doesn't make it, science
is not faith based, right?
That may be other ways. There may
be other things, you know, that way,
but not science.
Okay.
Science Ignores Divine Authority
and ignores human authority.
Not that they might not exist, but they
don't relate to science. Okay. Now,
as you walked in today,
did you notice these things over here?
There's an honor roll
of chemists and in fact,
we'll use that a lot this
semester. And in particular, uh,
one of the people on
there is Michael Faraday,
who started in a very humble way.
He was a bookbinders apprentice
and he bound this book,
not this particular copy,
but this book,
which is called
conversations on chemistry.
He bound the first edition.
This one is, is a later edition.
Yeah.
Let me,
so you see it's conversations on chemistry
in which elements of that science or
familiarly explained and illustrated
by experiments. And who's the author?
Jl Comstock is actually not the author.
He's the guy who stole it. Okay.
He stole it from a woman, Mrs
Marcet in England, who this book,
which was the most popular textbook.
It was written for girls,
but it was the most popular
textbook and all in all, uh, uh,
chemistry for the first
half of the 19th century.
It went through like a 20 some
additions in the, and here,
here you see at the beginning it's,
it's a dialogue,
a conversation between Mrs
B and Caroline and Emily.
And it's fun to see this here.
What Emily says at the beginning,
to confess the truth,
Mrs B,
I'm not disposed to form a very
favorable idea of chemistry,
nor do I expect to derive
much entertainment from
it. But in the long run,
as you can imagine, they have a
lot of fun with chemistry. That is,
it was a wonderful book and still is,
but he was binding it and read it.
And look what he says about this as
his introduction to be the leading
experimental scientist
of the 19th century.
Did not suppose I was a very deep thinker
or was marked as a precocious person.
I was a very lively,
imaginative person and could believe
in the Arabian nights as easily as the
encyclopedia. But facts were
important to me and saved me.
I could trust the fact and always
cross examined and assertion.
So when I questioned Mrs Marceto book by
such little experiments as I could find
means to perform and found it true to
the facts as I could understand them,
I felt I had got hold of an anchor and
chemical knowledge and clung fast to it.
Okay.
Right.
So the experiments were what bid it.
So the third way of knowing is
by experimental observation,
right?
And here's Richard Fineman.
How many of you heard of Richard
Vineman is a really great business,
wrote a wonderful textbook as well as
getting all sorts of prizes. And so he,
he spoke to the National Science Teachers
Association in 1966 say and learn from
science that you must doubt the experts.
Science is the belief and
the ignorance of experts.
When someone says science
teaches such and such,
he's using the word incorrectly.
Science doesn't teach it.
Experienced teaches it.
If they say to you,
science has shown such and such, you
might ask, how does science show it?
How did the scientists find out how,
what were not science has shown,
but this experiment or this
effect as shown right now,
why do we quote Fineman?
Because he's an expert.
Wrong.
Okay. The literally expert,
the, the etymology of experts.
That means someone who has
done experiments, okay,
we quote him because what
he says makes sense. Okay,
so logic is the fourth way of knowing
thing. So the two ways that we,
that we know things in
chemistry or in science,
our experiment and logic and the,
the lecture is a little
bit more focused on logic.
And the lab is more focused on experiment
and you get an unbalanced view if you
do one without the other.
Okay.
So modern science got underway in the
17th century. There's the 17th century,
1600 to 1700 right?
And 1638 was when new haven colony was
founded and 17 one was when Yale was
founded.
So that's when everything got underway.
Just when this enterprise was
beginning here, okay, here we are.
Okay.
If you go back a hundred years,
you get to quantum quantized nation
by Plonk and we'll talk about that.
And if you go back another hundred years,
you get to Lavoie Oza and oxidation.
And we'll talk about that.
And if you get another hundred years,
you get to Newton and gravitation.
And we'll talk a little bit about that.
And if you go back a little
more than another hundred years,
you get to Koepernick us and,
and the revolution of the heavenly bodies
and Columbus and navigation and Luther
and the reformation. And these
things all have something in common,
right? As Robert Hooke
wrote, the 17th century.
His Age was an age of all others,
the most inquisitive.
All these things have to do with people
inquiring into how people know things
and finding out new things.
Okay.
And in particular an important figure
was was Francis Bacon who and his instore
ration. Now you may not know the ins
duration, so well, let's look at that.
Here's Francis Bacon. There is
years. He, he was Elizabeth,
Ethan and Jacobean.
He was almost exactly contemporary
with Shakespeare and with Galileo.
He went to school at the university at
Cambridge and here's a cartoon that shows
him and imagine a,
it's a modern cartoon.
Imagine him in a class at
Cambridge because he wrote
of his tutors at Cambridge.
They were men of sharp wits,
shut up in their cells,
have a few authors, chiefly
Aristotle, their dictator,
right? All of the philosophy of nature,
philosophy meant science in those days.
All the philosophy of nature,
which has now received is either the
philosophy of the Grecians or that of the
alchemists.
The one is gathered out of a few vulgar.
That means common of course observations.
And the other out of a few
experiments have a furnace.
The one never fail us to multiply words
and the other ever fail us to multiply
gold.
Okay,
so here's the book he wrote the in store
Asian, that's the fraud piece for this.
Pictures from the Beinecke library work
done. You got a picture of the book.
Okay. Notice it was published in
1620. What else happened then?
That's when the pilgrims
came over. Right? Okay.
So the title of the book rather small
under his name and title is Lord
Chancellor of England
is in star Osseo Magdna,
which means the great
restoration restoration of what?
Of the way of knowing, right? This
the uh, a bigger a part of it.
It's called the Nobu Morgano,
which is then it develops the inductive
scientific method based on experiment to
replace Aristotelian deduction,
which is you maybe did one experiment
sometime and then you reason everything
from that. But he says, no, you
have to do more experiments. Now,
there's an interesting thing here.
The device on one of the devices
on the title or this, uh,
frontest piece is two pillars.
What are the world are they doing there?
Well,
they're the same pillars
that you see on this.
That's a piece of eight, you know,
treasure island pieces of eight c,
it's eight radiologists,
and it came from the silver of
Mexico was minted in Mexico City,
right?
So there you'll see the same pillars
and on them it says pluse ultra more
beyond,
beyond what,
what are the pillars?
Pardon me?
Africa.
It's, yeah, it's, it's Africa and Spain,
but it's the pillars of Hercules,
which are the mouth of the Mediterranean,
the old classical world,
right?
So there's the mountain of Moses and
Morocco and the mountain of Tariq,
which is the name of Gibraltar,
right? So here's the Mediterranean,
the classical world of Aristotle.
And you could say allowed into the new
world and bring back silver for example.
Right?
There's danger of course,
right?
Okay.
But look what it says at the bottom,
what we'll be brought back,
not just silver,
right? Molted paratransit Bonet
at our gay be towards CNTR.
Many will pass through and
knowledge will be increased,
right?
So we go beyond Aristotle
into experimentally based
science and knowledge will
be increased. So here's some quotes
from the install Roseo Magdna
that wisdom which we have derived
principally from the Greeks. No offense,
okay.
Uh,
is but like the boy hood of knowledge
and has the characteristic property of
boys.
It can talk but it cannot generate
good.
It is. But a device for exempting
ignorance from ignominy.
That means it's a way of hiding
your ignorance and we'll see.
We'll see examples of that.
We'll talk about in lecture 11 about
Correlation Energy and we'll talk and
lecture 32 about strain energy.
And you'll see that both of these are
just words that are used to hide our
ignorance.
Okay.
The end,
which this science of mind proposes is
the invention not have arguments but of
arts ways of doing things right?
Not so much by instruments,
although new instruments are
important like microscopes and so on,
as by experiments skillfully
and artificially devised
for the express purpose of
determining the point in question.
So artificial experiments
designed to decide a question,
experiments.
And this will lead to the restoration
of learning and knowledge.
So followers of of Bacon established
the Royal Society and 1662 just after
Charles was restored, uh, to England
after the period of chrom. Well,
and there was a history written of the
Royal Society of book about this thick,
published in 1667 only five
years after it was founded.
Why did they publish a history so
sued, well, let's look at this. The,
the hottest piece of this book.
Here's the late Francis Bacon who is said
to be RTM in store at are the restorer
of the arts.
Okay.
And here's the president of the Royal
Society of the mathematician bike out
brown sugar.
And here in the middle being crowned
with Laurel is Charles the second.
Why do they have him up on a pedestal?
How's their hope hoping the science
scientists have before and ever since to
extract some money out of the
government to do their research?
They actually never got it from Charles,
but that wasn't for lack of trying.
And this is why they wrote the history
to try to make the case for being
supported.
Okay.
Now let's look at all the good
things that will come from science,
from the Royal Society in the background.
Can you see what that is?
We'll blow it up.
Hear it.
There's a hint to it on the bookshelf.
If you look really fine on the bookshelf,
you can see that some of them have titles.
Have a writ writing on the spine.
Do you see what that one is?
Anybody read it?
What?
What science book do you think
they might had? Copernicus,
right, so astronomy, that's
a telescope in the back.
Okay. Or over here on the
wall. What's that thing?
It's a clock. Why is it shaped
like a piece of Pie? Oh,
cause it has a pendulum inside.
Okay,
so ornithology making good
clocks. Okay. Or here.
What's that thing that's
hard for you to know?
It's a wind gauge. It's, it has
a vein inside that blows on.
You can tell from how far it goes on
the scale, how strong the wind is.
So meteorology and back
here on the pillar.
But are those things for,
yeah,
for cartography right now,
what do all these things have in common
that they're going to do for Charles?
The second
astronomy,
good clocks. Meteorology
cartography. What book?
They all have to do with
navigation, right? With making,
uh,
England strong at sea.
Now back here is another science.
Chemistry.
Okay.
That doesn't seem to have
anything to do with navigation.
Why would chemistry be
important to Charles?
Look at it
to make gun powder.
There was a chapter about gunpowder in
the history of the royal society. Okay.
And up here at the top is the motto,
which is newly use in whereby,
which comes from this quote from Horace.
And what it says is less,
you asked who leads me in
what household I lodge.
That is what philosophy I advocate.
There is no master in whose words I am
bound to take an oath wherever the storm
forces me there I put in as the guest.
So it's the experiment,
not the philosopher that
leads you to the conclusion,
right? So newly use and whereby
is in the words of none.
Okay.
And in fact,
the original name of the Royal Society
was the Royal Society for the improving
of natural knowledge by experiments.
Yeah.
Okay. So we're going to see
as the course goes along,
important experiments that
really decided questions.
And in fact Bacon's most important
kind of experiment was one that finally
decides between two rival hypothesis,
proven the one and disproving the other.
So you can do all sorts of experiments
and just be collecting butterflies. No,
I don't mean to insult people who quite
butterflies. It's a fine thing to do,
but there's something special experiments
that really are designed to answer a
question right now.
The bacon devise the name
for such experiments and
they're based on this model
that you have a road that diverges and
you need to know which way to go between
these two hypotheses.
What do you need to know?
Which way to go?
You need a sign or this was a cross
that would be mounted at a crossroads.
Okay, so the root, the Latin
name for cross is crux. Yeah.
See what they call the experiment.
Crucial. That's the origin
of the word crucial, right?
It's the one that tells
you which way to go. Okay,
so here is Isaac Newton
and he's holding something.
Can you see what he's holding in his hand?
I'll give you a hint.
It's a prison.
Why is he holding a prison?
Because that was his crucial experiment.
And here's his diagram of that
experiment with a prisoner.
He called it the experimental crutches,
taking the word from Bacon.
Okay? So light came in through a
hole in the window through a Lens,
and then got bent and dispersed
into the different colors.
So you've got a spectrum here on this
thing, the different colors, okay?
Now there's the question.
How does the prism make color
hook?
And Descartes thought that that
light was a train of pulses,
and as it goes through
something like a prism,
or as reflects from a thin layer of
oil on water or something like that,
that it changes the timing of the
pulses and therefore changes the color,
right?
But Newton thought that the colors
were preexisting and the prison just
separates them.
And this was his crucial experiment
to decide between those two theories.
You see what he did?
He drilled a hole through the board and
let through only the red light and put a
second prism there,
right?
And he wrote here three times,
he wrote it here and also here and
also here neck Variani looks from the
[inaudible] which means the broken
light does not change its color,
right? So this proved to
Newton, at least at that time,
that light is a substance,
not a train of pulses.
What do you think of that proof?
Now you think light is a substance
or a train of pulses. Photo not,
but at least you can see that in terms
then that was a crucial experiment,
a really important experiment.
And that's the kind of experiments
we'll try to talk about in the course.
Experiments are indispensable
in organic chemistry.
It's an empirical science
based on observation and
that's why you have to take
the lab.
But so his logic now,
that was number three and number four of
the ways of knowing logic is important
too.
So believe what I tell you here,
only when it makes sense to you,
don't just cram it in.
Make sure it makes sense.
But what if it doesn't?
Okay.
Now here's how to succeed in count one
25 and we'll take as our model science
student Samuel peeps. How many
people have heard of Samuel peeps?
If you heard of him as a scientist,
what did you hear of the Mat?
What do you associate with Samuel peeps?
Right in this period.
Right in the heart of the science growth.
But what you know him for was his diary,
which tells all about life everyday
life in restoration London.
Okay.
He was actually as a 16 year old present
when Charles the first was beheaded in
1649 now,
what's the connection?
You know where this is?
Is anybody been there?
Dixwell golf and Wally avenues.
Those are named from three four,
three of the 50 judges that condemn
Charles the first to be beheaded and they
were the only ones that lasted very long
after the restoration and they lasted
because they fled to New England
and were hidden on West Rock.
All these roads are heading
west toward restaurant. Okay,
so that's the tie into the same period.
But anyway,
he had got his Ba in Cambridge and 1654
and a master's in 1656 and he got a good
job. He became Clark of the
acts for the navy board,
which meant he was the guy that
purchased everything for the Royal Navy,
all the rope, all the tar,
all the lumber and so on.
And on July 4th, 1662 I
mean, it's the 4th of July,
but it's more than a hundred years
before that became relevant. Right?
He writes in his diary by
and by comes Mr. Cooper,
mate of the Royal Charles of who am I
intend to learn mathematics and do begin
with him today.
He being a very able man after an
hour's being with him at arithmetic,
my first attempt being to
learn the multiplication table.
We then parted till tomorrow.
So here was the guy doing
all the purchasing for the
Royal Navy and he didn't
know multiply multiplication,
let alone division,
but he worked hard at it.
July 9th five days later,
he's up by four o'clock and that
my multiplication table hard,
which is all the trouble I meet
with all in the arithmetic,
he can do the other things pretty well.
Okay.
July 11 up by four o'clock on
heart at my multiplication table,
which I have now almost master of
Christmas, right? So six months later,
soda my office practicing Arithmetic
alone and making an end of last night's
book with great content till 11 at night.
And so home to supper and
bed or a year later. Oh,
so he was motivated and he was diligent.
That's good.
Okay.
A year later on,
a Sunday I below by myself looking over
my arithmetic books and timber rule.
So my wife arose a nod and she and I all
the afternoon at Arithmetic and she has
come to do addition,
subtraction and multiplication very well.
And so I purpose not to trouble
her yet with division. Right?
So we worked with a study
partner and that's crucial.
And Isaac Newton,
does anybody recognize this book?
Right though? The mathematical principles
of science of natural philosophy.
But there's an interesting
thing on the title page.
Samuel peeps is the one who
gave permission to publish
that book because he was
the president of the Royal Society.
Yeah.
Now, six years later, peeps
encountered a problem with dice.
The reason was he went to coffee shops
every night for dinner and they'd gamble,
right?
And people proposed various kinds of
bets and he couldn't figure out this one.
So he wrote Newton for help.
Okay.
So this was the problem that he
wrote to Newton and 22nd of November.
So a has six dice in a box and he asked
to throw a six by throwing it right?
B has 12 dice and he has to fling
two sixes and see has 18 dice,
but he has to get three sixes to win
the question whether B and c have not as
easy a task at a at even lock. That is,
if the dice aren't loaded or anything,
who has the better bet?
How many people think that it's the same?
Don't be shy.
How many think it's a?
How many think B? How many things? See
how many don't really have any
opinion at all. Good. That wins.
Okay.
So he wrote this letter to try to get
help on his bets from Newton and Newton
replied four days later.
What is the expectation or hope
of a to throw every time one,
six at least with 6,000 so you get
to six is you still win, right?
That wasn't clear in the
original statement. So he says,
if we formulate the question that way,
it appears an easy computation that the
expectation of a is greater than BRC.
That is the task of a is the easiest.
There's the answer.
So peeps replied on the 6th of December,
you give it in favor of the
expectations of a, and this, as you say,
by an easy computation,
but yet I must not pretend to so much
conversation with numbers as presently to
comprehend as I ought to do all the
force of that which you are pleased to
assign for the reason of it relating to
their having or not having the benefit
of all their chances.
So he wasn't ashamed to admit
that he didn't really understand.
That's crucial.
Okay.
And therefore were it not for the trouble,
it must have cost you.
I could have wished for a
site of the very computation.
Can you show me how to figure it out?
And he wanted that because somebody might
change the terms of the bet and that
he wouldn't know. He wanted really
to understand. He insisted on proof.
Yeah.
So this is two of the pages from Newton's
correspondence of the letter that he
wrote in response.
And you can see that that peeps certainly
got more than he had bargained for.
So it to compute this, I sat down in
the following progressions of numbers.
So you can go through all this
and you get complicated, uh, uh,
quotients here.
And it turns out that a has
30 1031 chances out of 46,000,
656 or 0.6, six five,
one chance of winning,
and B has this, which is 0.6, one
eight, seven, sorry, 0.6, one eight,
seven a wins. Right? So,
so this peep satisfied with this.
Peeps writes back and he says, why, right?
I cannot bear the thought of
being made master of a jewel.
I know not how to wear right.
So he's willing to swallow his pride to
search for really solid understanding.
Now compare this with a
comment we got at the end,
at the end of semester valuation
in January a year ago, okay.
I never went to his office hours for
help because I felt like he would make me
feel stupid because he's
superior to be in chemistry.
I hope I'm superior to you in chemistry.
I'm not superior as a person,
but I hope I'm superior in chemistry.
You're paying me the big bucks, right?
Because that, so swallow your
pride and ask someone for help.
Okay,
follow peeps.
So read peeps and Newton and get together
to do problems for for Monday and
contribute to the Wiki
when you're asked to do so.
So here are problems for Friday. The
problems are optional, but very helpful.
One is find out which two class have the
rooms nearest you so that you can maybe
use them as study partners.
You don't have to use that.
Use anybody but use someone.
Don't try to go out alone to what are the
three most common items of advice from
course veterans. So if you click
there or go to the webpage,
you can get anonymous advice,
right?
I was careful to make it.
Sure it's anonymous. Uh,
so you could get all fly
much of it as contradictory.
So your job is to look through it and
try to get some idea of what they're
telling you that's worth knowing
for Monday, their problems from,
from that webpage peeps in Newton.
And let me tell you that you better
get together with other people to do it
because there's a lot of stuff there.
So I'll get together in a group
parcel out who works on what,
discuss what went on and so on.
And then for a week from Friday,
uh, there's stuff about drawing Lewis
structures from another webpage about
functional groups.
So we'll get to that later.
I just wanted you to know what's coming up
in this.
Incidentally,
this thing about the,
the problem set that has to do with the
mathematics that Newton and peeps we're
working on there has to do
with isotope ratios. You know,
the chlorine has a funny
atomic weight. Why? What,
what is the atomic weight?
[inaudible] 35 and a half.
Why a half? All the other,
most of the elements are,
are pretty near integers.
It's because it's a mixture of isotopes,
right? It's a quarter of one isotopes
and three quarters of the other.
And the average is 35 and a half,
35 and 37
but in fact,
it depends on where you get chlorine from,
what the ratio is. Here's 35 and a half,
right? For the standard atomic weight.
But it ranges quite,
quite a bit depending on where you get it.
So by measuring these ratios,
which is a lot like these
odds in the bedding,
you can tell where things came from,
you can tell where hydrocarbons
came from sometimes that way.
And those are the problems that
you have to deal with. So it's,
it's not really very,
very relevant to the course as a whole,
but it's relevant to the peeps and
Newton thing and it's a fun problem.
So that's what you gotta do for Monday.
Okay.
And here are the assignments. I emailed
all these people, I hope you're here. So,
and that you've picked up on what we
talked about today so that you can improve
the wikis from last year,
last year.
People develop their wikis
from scratch this time.
So she's a very valuable thing to do. So
I was torn this year as to whether have,
whether to have you do them from
scratch or whether to modify last year.
I figured modifying last year is better
because then you have something to read
earlier on for those who are
not working on developing it.
So anyhow, but, but the hope
is so if you, if you modify it,
it has to be some significant,
not put a comment or something like that,
but add something useful to understanding.
Uh,
if you do it within 36 hours,
you get two points.
And if what you do is really
good, you get three points. Okay.
So you go, you go to that page
and you click on those things.
Then you can read what are you hitting?
Either modify and Margherita,
that's a Wiki. Now we come to the
question that will address more,
we have another five minutes here.
The question we're really dealing with
now having seen how to work in chem on 25
is are their atoms and molecules.
How do you know?
Right?
And what force holds them together.
Because if we knew what if we knew that
they're real and we knew what force held
them together, then in principle we
might be able to calculate everything,
right?
So it would all be theory.
So is it springs that
hold the atoms together?
So Robert Boyle notices
right at that time,
1627 to 1691 and he's the oldest person
that's on the honor roll outside.
The building here is over that way.
Uh,
so Robert Boyle wrote this first
important book in Chemistry,
new experiments, physical, mechanical,
touching the spring of air,
right?
So you know Boyle's law, right? How
pressure and volume change that.
That air in a piston acts like a spring.
And so PV is a constant,
that's Boyle's law.
So it was [inaudible].
He developed this science on
the basis of a new instrument,
that new magical engine,
which was built by Robert Hook,
the guy that we quoted,
and there's a picture of the of the air
pump here with that crank on it and so
odd to pump things in or out of that,
of that bulb.
Now, a couple of years
later, Hook wrote this book,
Lectures de Potentia,
RST Tootie or of spring explaining
the power of springing bodies,
and this is the beginning of that book.
The theory of springs though attempted
by diverse eminent mathematicians of this
age,
has either to not been published by any,
it is now about 18 years
since I first found it out,
but designing to apply it
to some particular use,
I omitted the publishing thereof,
so he kept it secret,
so no one would steal the idea.
What did he hope to do with a spring?
Yeah,
a really important
technology that he could do with a spray.
It was a coiled spring that he invented
a new kind of clock,
right?
One that could work better for navigation
was his spring that actually allowed
Harrison a hundred years later to win
the contest about making an accurate
clock. Some of you must
know that story. So anyhow,
he had been hiding this so it
wouldn't be stolen. In fact,
it was stolen by Huygens,
so about three years since his majesty
was pleased to see the experiment that
made out this theory, tried at
Whitehall, and also my spring watch
about two years since I printed the
theory in an Anagram at the end of my book
on the description of
Healia scopes vis this.
So this is what he published at the
end of this book on Helias scopes
and that is an Anagram
of how springs work,
right?
So that later he could prove
that he knew it if needs be,
but no one could steal it in the meantime.
All right. And if you unscramble it,
it's 10 CEO Sick V's.
That is the power of any spring is in
the same proportion with the tension
thereof. That is if one power
stretcher bend at one space,
two will suppress it to three,
we'll bend it three and so forward.
So here's this figure that shows that
that's Hooke's law. The forest law,
the force is proportional
to the distortion, right?
So here's his figure,
and he's got plots of it here.
What's 10 CEO as the extension?
Sick V's.
So the force, so it's linear,
right? The, the forest is how much,
how much you stretch it.
And he has lots of different kinds of
springs that do that. Here's this clock,
kind of spring, a coil spring,
just stretching a wire.
So the force is proportional
to the extension.
Or another way of saying is the potential
energy is proportional to the square
of the extension. So it's a
parabola. So that's Hooke's law,
right? And that's where
it will take up next time.